We know that this other city is directly east of Grant's hometown. So, we're not
moving in the up and down or north and south direction at all when we go from
here to here. We're only moving horizontally, which only changes the
x-coordinate. We're moving over 200 miles so the x-coordinate becomes 200. Since
you've moved 200 miles over from zero in the positive direction, and the y
coordinate doesn't change at all. It stays as zero. We know that Udacity is
directly north of this other city. So, if we move from the other city up to
Udacity, all that we're changing is the y-coordinate, since we're only moving
vertically. That means that the horizontal coordinate stays the same, but it
needs to be the coordinate of this other city. So, Udacity is located at 200,
and it's y-coordinate will be 0 plus 700, or 700.